the matter that I'm going to give you my
proverbial to Sense on has to do with
questions and answers and it can be
framed as a question a meta question if
you will is it better or is it more
important to ask questions or is it more
important to acquire answers to the
questions that you have and I do have an
answer to this but it's kind of a a
longish one and so we're going to wander
around some topics and this is the way
that you actually engage in thoughtful
inquiry so in in a certain respect we're
modeling one way not the only way but
one way that a person might engage in
that and before I address all of this
I'm going to tell you a little story so
I was in a job interview and we're
talking about about six years ago and
you know things were going well enough
and it was for a visiting assistant
professor position which would have me
teaching a lot and it was with the
assistant chair and the chair of a
philosophy
department and you know everything was
going great until we got to a certain
point and I believe what I was actually
being asked about was what are you
trying to do in a intro to philosophy
class what are you trying to give to
your students and I talked about you
know something having to do with
questions you know the big questions and
then we look at answers that have been
provided throughout the history of
philosophy and we determine which of
these are actually good answers for the
students and I think that it's important
for students to learn how to develop
their own answers to these questions
incorporating other people's ideas and
you could tell as sometimes is the case
that the the temperature in the room had
gone down right and the assistant chair
was fine with that answer but the chair
who was a older guy definitely a boomer
said oh you know I think what's most
important what I found in my experience
is most important
is getting the students to ask questions
not giving them answers and you know I
didn't want to offend the guy so I
didn't uh go against him on that I said
well that's that's interesting you know
multiple approaches I suppose we could
take but I thought to myself man have I
heard that so many times in my career
and it probably showed on my face that I
was like oh one of those people one of
those I just love to ask questions types
and I got something like that again
recently in a YouTube comment I don't
remember the specifics of it but
somebody was again sort of opining about
how important it is that we ask
questions that's much more important
than finding the answers and you know
I've always thought no that's not right
um there's there's a lot of cases where
we do want to be asking questions
sometimes there's questions that were we
should be asking that we're not and
we'll talk about that in just a moment
but what is the purpose of a question
it's to get an answer isn't it I mean
the whole process isn't just to keep on
asking questions over and over and over
again that's kind of self-indulgent kind
of fruitless kind of silly in some
respects and so I want to do a little
bit of uh opining of my own of my own
reflections on this sort of thing so the
first thing I want to say is that yes in
philosophy we often do talk about we're
going to address the big questions what
is real how do we know anything how
should I live can I believe that there's
a higher power the these are questions
right and you can also frame them as
subject matters you can frame them as
problems you can frame them in a number
of different ways and you know
philosophy doesn't successfully resolve
them if by successfully you resolve
means you get every single practitioner
on board with one single set of answers
that's true right but
um question doesn't always mean the same
thing we could think for example about
you know Martin haiger and his famous
essay the question concerning technology
and you got to actually like read a good
bit before you can figure what the
hell's the question in there right he's
going to tell you an awful lot of things
and you know uh there there this is sort
of a big gigantic thing or we can talk
about even further the question of being
doign is the being that questions being
and questions indeed its own being
that's very different than asking for
directions or saying is this going to be
on the test or how do I write this paper
or is is this even you know a valid
argument or a sound argument or things
that are kind of lower level questions
so I don't I think if we're going to say
it's really important to ask questions
we want to clarify what kind of
questions are we talking about and too
many people just use question as if it's
this big blank question mark and it can
be anything that you like so that's an
equivocation and I think that could be
kind of problematic itself right could
ask questions about that I think it's
important to say that there are a lot of
times when we do want to ask questions
and if we're doing philosophy or we're
doing any other sort of thoughtful
discipline that you could study and make
progress in you do have to ask questions
you have to ask a lot of questions um
but do you just want to do that and when
when is it important to stress asking
questions or why is it important to
stress this
um you know opening
Alternatives engaging in inquiry all
these things that we kind of figure into
that having an open mind being willing
to entertain ideas so you know if you're
in a situation a cultural situation
family situation where everybody has all
the answers and there's too many Pat
answers too many answers that are kind
of thoughtless that everybody's just
well there's the answer to it already
you don't need to think about it at all
you don't need to ask any questions
you've already got all the answers there
for you okay then you might want to ask
questions and one of the questions might
be how do you know that those are the
right answers or why do we have to
accept these answers or where do these
answers come from right so you can
always ask questions even if people have
tried to cut you off and keep you from
doing that and I think it makes sense
when the answers are
unsatisfying for us to to open up the
possibility of questions and maybe we
need to do that in our classes right
maybe philosophy has this important
function of doing that um I think too
that with people who have been trained
or conditioned or you know even like uh
terrorized into not asking questions
just accepting answers it can often be
very helpful
to help them learn how to ask questions
for themselves and maybe models of other
people asking questions that could be
you know useful in that let's call it
apprenticeship in the development of the
human mind right and this would extend
not just to people who don't get to ask
questions at all but people who are only
allowed to ask questions within certain
limits like you ask questions about this
but don't ask questions about like the
larger totality that you're involved in
and I'll just give you example of that
so my friend Gary when I was in graduate
school he told me this story I don't
know if it's actually true or not but
it's a great story anyway and it
probably happened to somebody he was an
economics major and he would ask a lot
of questions in class and the questions
were not well how does this actually
work the questions were how do you know
that this works or where did this stuff
come from or why are you asserting this
as like a law or a generalization that
we can count on in every case and after
a certain amount of those questions they
were like you know what you need to go
over to philosophy that's where they ask
all these sorts of questions and he he's
like and that was an answer by the way
and he was like okay I guess I'll go
over over to philosophy and I'll take
classes with them and then he became a
philosophy major and he went on to
graduate school in philosophy and he
eventually became a professor right so
there's lots of things like that ask too
many questions that people are
uncomfortable with or don't have the
answers to or haven't thought about and
you know they'll try to push you
somewhere where people do ask questions
nothing wrong with questions as such I
do think there are problems with the
kind of people who think that questions
are the main thing that matters and
answers are not as important as
questions at a certain point just asking
questions over and over and over again
winds up being pointless or annoying or
a waste of time in a certain way
self-indulgent I think there's a lot of
people who derive a kind of prestige
from it they're like oh I'm just asking
people qu I'm like Socrates right well
no you're not like Socrates Socrates if
you actually look at the dialogues in
which we see him represented knew a lot
of things he knew what sort of questions
to ask people at the right time he
wasn't just going around randomly
questioning everything he wasn't being a
rebel for its own sake he wasn't being
just a
non-conformist uh you know a
non-conformist the same old way as every
other other non-conformist does right
which is not to be a
non-conformist and so I think that some
people really get off on this and that
makes those
people not just irritating or full of
themselves but it lets them put
themselves in the way of people who want
to get on with the real business of
thoughtful you know answering of or
thoughtful inquiry into things um
obviously we do need to ask questions we
do need to wonder about things which is
related to asking questions we do need
to
problematize a lot of things probably
more than we in fact realize um
and we need to do that in order to get
to answers answers are you could say the
end the goal the tellos the purpose of
asking questions if you're just asking
questions to get Social clout or annoy
people or to keep from having to do
things you're kind of missing the point
aren't you um when we ask questions we
ultimately hopefully do want um
questions or answers and the other thing
that I'm going to
say very often the people who are like
oh man it's all about the questions not
the answers that you
get or the answers you know that's like
ending the inquiry not a good thing we
need to keep it open keep it
going what they don't take into account
which they should know from their own
experience is when you answer a question
you hav't like oop all done we'll never
think about this matter again if you're
really really working on things really
thinking about things what do you
actually find when you answer a
question it it the answer doesn't solve
every single thing as a matter of fact
it opens up as we often say a new can of
worms right a new set of questions that
then can be approached because we
actually made a little bit of progress
we got somewhere and now we can ask
better questions we can ask more more
interesting questions we can ask deeper
questions we can ask more complex
questions if we stop ourselves early on
and we're like we're not going to take
any stances we're not going to be
dogmatic we're not going to stick with
any answers that keeps us from being
able to ask questions that we want to
ask it actually blocks the road to
inquiry we have to answer things and
accept answers along the way
provisionally and and sometimes even
permanently as a condition for being
able to get into the better
questions um another thing that we want
to think about when we get answers it's
not as if we get one answer over here
and that's got nothing to do with the
other answer over here or the other
answer over here we live a life and we
have a mind and a heart and all these
answers coexist with within a person but
they don't always coexist
peacefully they may conflict they may be
in contradiction they may cause
cognitive dissonance they may raise
notice what I'm going to say here all
sorts of other questions by the way that
they don't get along with each other so
having answers isn't really you know
stopping you from asking questions your
answers might not all fit in together
and that will cause you to ask
additional questions about well which of
these answers should I keep and which
should I throw away or is it possible
perhaps to harmonize these together uh
the last thing that I'm going to say
here I think that there's a lot of
people who are you know quite focused on
providing the right answer having the
right answer um but they do so in sort
of a slip shot you know lazy way where
the answers aren't really part of who
they are think about cramming for an
examination right so you're going to
take this test and the test is important
because your grade depends on it or it's
going to you know allow you to get some
college credit because you're taking an
AP test or something like that and so
you cram your head full of answers and
then when you're ask the right questions
like a stimulus response machine you to
churn them out right and then you forget
all that stuff it hasn't become part of
you those answers in a certain way don't
matter to
you well that's not the way that you
have to approach questions and answers
you can be interested in something and
you'll ask questions and you'll get
answers along the way and you'll look at
what other people's answers are too and
you'll say are these in fact good
answers and you're asking questions you
work out new answers I think it's really
important and this is maybe what the
origin of this ooh man it's all about
the questions not about the answers uh
line or Trope comes from we want to get
in the habit of finding answers for
ourselves that's what it means to be an
independent human being to be a
thoughtful person to be able to get by
in the world and so that means that we
have to figure things out that means
that we have to determine where we're
going to find answers and which kind of
answers are good answers and so there's
a dialectic constantly going on for
intelligent thoughtful people between
questions and answers but it doesn't
mean that we have to like say oh answers
aren't any good because as soon as we
have an answer we're no longer thinking
we're turning our brains off and
questioning is the real activity no
answers are the goal they're just quite
often not our final resting place
and so I want to say if anything matters
more it's actually the answers and good
luck getting them because you're going
to have to ask some questions along the
way and they're not going to necessarily
drive all the questions away so I I I
don't buy this thing of O questions are
the real game in town you know answers
that's for the squares that's for the
people who think they've got everything
figured out I've been asking and
answering questions myself and
philosophy now for over 30 years and I
don't expect to be done anytime soon and
I want my students as best as you know I
can convey to them to get some sort of
idea that that could be a valuable way
of living and to get a little bit of
practice in my classes about it so you
know is there a nice easy Pat answer to
this question this meta question about
questions and answers turns out no but
hopefully that gives you some thoughts
some Reflections which you don't have to
necessarily buy as the answer but you've
got something that might grip might have
some traction for you as you think about
these matters for
yourself
that